[Music]
2021 might not have lived up to be the
savior of 2020 as we all originally
hoped it to be but you know what at
least the anime was pretty banging
right
[Music]
this year was the year of anime that we
deserved after 2020. there was so much
great stuff that came out this year that
when picking my favorites i had to be
pretty cutthroat in what i talked about
today or we'd be here all day b stars 2
dragon maid 2 and slime 2 won't be
making my list because even though i
watch them all and love them i don't
have anything interesting to say about
them other than yeah it's more the same
good [ __ ] in it jujitsu kaisen and my
previous anime of the year re zero
pretty much continued what i said about
them last year so if it was a sequel or
continuation i didn't have anything more
interesting to add it's cut but before
we get to the best shows i saw let's see
all the other amazing things that
happened for anime in 2021 hello
the year started off with x arm an anime
that broke new records by being one of
the lowest rated anime to come out on
mal on release an anime that had more
bugs than cyberpunk by a team that had
never worked on an anime before
to the surprise of everybody that made
berserk 2017 look like violet evergarden
using animation techniques never before
seen in the history of the medium
in summary anime of the year not to be
outdone after years of radio silence
high guardian spice dropped to stunning
praise i mean just look at this the
opening has 9 000 likes and not a single
dislike i guess everyone enjoyed it a
lot of people refused to call this anime
at all but how could you not when this
is clearly the most accurate adaptation
we've ever gotten of those early 2000s
how to draw manga books not also
forgetting we got the groundbreaking
release of the revolutionary biopic
about the greatest gamer to ever live
redo of healer completing quests like
its final fantasy collecting chicks like
its pokemon healing [ __ ] like its
overwatch and for his ultimate move
enchanting dicks like its minecraft what
a true gamer honestly shock value aside
i would have preferred this just be a
proper hentai with full-length scenes so
i don't have to pretend to give a [ __ ]
about the writing i think it speaks
wonders that redo tried so bad to be
offensive not even twitter was offended
because it was so bad overall history
deleted phone used holy water needed
meat
let me get this straight one of the
wealthiest most powerful men in the
world is secretly a vigilante and your
plan
is to blackmail this person
i'm right it is because you are black
and you are male after much anticipation
netflix released their reimagining of
cowboy bebop and i mean what can i say
you got fantastic scripting straight out
of seinfeld vicious looks just as
threatening as a dogecoin millionaire
and i'm happy for all these cast members
getting another great acting gig what
what happened to james
um john cho's [ __ ] killing it on a
sick hit netflix show that's what
happened to john show
promised neverland season two thought it
would be a good idea to skip 60 odd
chapters worth of content containing one
of the most beloved arcs of the manga to
skip right to the end and kind of hope
that people just wouldn't notice
shockingly they did one piece celebrated
its 1000th episode which is an
absolutely amazing achievement showing
that one piece fans are unmatched in
their sheer commitment to one thing
proving that they are in fact the ideal
life partner anyone could hope for
if it was actually possible for a
one-piece fan to get laid speaking of
not getting laid evangelion fans were
finally recorded
i don't know why i'm making these tricks
i'm an ava fan and a one-piece fan
evangelion fans were finally rewarded as
evangelion was three plus one twenty one
as fans were given the one ending no one
ever expected
an actual [ __ ] ending yes long time
fans like myself were finally able to
say goodbye as evangelion turned around
one last time and said good night good
morning
thank you
and finally hello hello honestly it's
hard to put into words the wave of
emotion i felt watching a franchise so
dear to my heart actually being put to
rest but even so there was something
else this year that hit me even harder
every so often we come across someone in
history that seemingly been able to
immortalize themselves through their
work someone standing at the pinnacle of
their craft setting the standard their
fellow peers aspire to reach and
inspiring countless others with a sphere
of influence you'll never be able to
directly quantify
but you feel it someone like this
doesn't appear every day but if there is
a person out there who i think can claim
that title
it's
kintaro miura
berserk is a title that should need no
introduction a manga that's constantly
at the top of everyone's favorites of
all time it's a gruesome story with some
of the most nightmarish imagery you can
find anywhere in the medium yet i can't
think of any other way to describe this
tale other than
beautiful there's a soul to berserk i
can't even begin to describe but i can
feel it emanating from every panel as
though a piece of miura himself was
etched into every page it's something
that went beyond the medium of manga a
craft we rarely ever get to see and now
something we'll never be able to see the
end of
in times like these it can be easy to
lament the things that we'll never be
able to experience we'll never be able
to see griffith's kingdom the ancient
king's full backstory guts finding his
revenge and closing off the final
chapter of everything he's been through
but to me no matter what things we'll
never get the chance to see in the
future what we were lucky enough to get
the chance to bear witness to in the
first place will always trump that you
were able to bear witness to a lost soul
finding purpose in life in a place he
really shouldn't have been able to you
were able to bear witness to someone who
had found beauty in the most hellish of
places you were able to bear witness to
one man who never gave up on life never
stopped fighting never backed down when
not a single soul would have blamed him
for doing so
you were able to bear witness to one of
the greatest stories ever told
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's get to it
anime has conditioned me into thinking
every romance needs a little bit of
drama a little bit of conflict a little
bit of spice but what happens when you
present me the anime spice master a
completely spiceless vanilla romance
about people who like each other then
end up together with little resistance
turns out it's pretty damn good horimia
proves that you don't need some
complicated love dodecahedron to have a
great anime romance the most
extraordinary thing it does is how many
unextraordinary things happen in it well
that's exactly what makes it so great
it's so casual so unbelievably real that
it's comforting you see this girl well
she heard her boyfriend was hanging out
with another girl and getting a bit
chummy i know you're thinking right
classic misunderstanding that is until
she did this one simple trick every
romance writer hates her for she asked
him about it and he explained it to her
this is some kind of twisted joke it's
just refreshing seeing characters like
each other get together then act like
mature [ __ ] people and watching this
made me realize that you know what a
nice wholesome simple vanilla
relationship is the best thing any
person can hope for
can you come help me pick up the
evangelion arnold holes i just got the
50 kilogram anime titties in the mail
and i had to go pick up the [ __ ] of the
round table too so i could really use
your help a little bit here okay
[Music]
in a medium with some of the most
decorated sci-fi shows of all time you'd
think it wouldn't take this long before
some exec would have the realization of
huh
maybe a star wars anime would be a good
idea star wars visions is what happens
if we give a bunch of talented creators
and studios the budget and creator
freedom to do whatever they want with an
ip and see if they can deliver which
they did nine stories filled with
wonderful ideas that pushed the
imagination of what we've seen in the
star wars universe and the concert
episode i'll be honest i'm not even a
star wars fan except for two things
jedis and lightsaber battles and oh boy
we've got light sabers that look like
katanas this chick has a lightsaber
umbrella that she uses to helicopter
into a fight this dude uses a crystal to
supercharge his lightsaber into a
rainbow super saver so he can go out
hyperspeed while standing on the nose of
an x-wing so i can tear a [ __ ] star
destroyer in half the [ __ ] had so much
lightsaber porn general grievous had to
watch it in incognito mode star wars
visions is the star wars i wanted from
star wars it reels you into a corner of
this amazing universe then spits you off
for the next exciting exhilarating ride
before you have a chance to catch your
breath and i really hope we don't have
to wait as long again to see the next
anime set a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away
[Music]
with the amount of sequels these days
that feels more like a quick cash grab
my gut reaction seeing any continuation
for a story that's already clearly
finished is just
stop it the original megalo box detailed
the rise of gearless show and his
journey of winning the prestigious
boxing tournament of megalonia and by
the season end everything was wrapped up
the character arc was complete the plot
threads were tied up the story was over
there was nowhere left for this tale to
go nomad was a sequel i didn't want or
asked for yet somehow it managed to
exceed its predecessor in just about
every way possible forget a boxing anime
with some character development this was
a character-driven drama with some
boxing in it it took the hero it had so
carefully built up and completely broke
him depression drug abuse managing grief
this is joe in megalo box season 1 and
this is joe
post 2020 joe's story is no longer a
simple rise to fame underdog tale it's
an introspective saga of the fall of a
hero the inability to live up to legacy
and the struggle for redemption that
comes after it this is the benchmark of
how to make a sequel to a story that's
already ended showing us there's always
a new angle to explore a new place to
take a character because there's always
something that happens after happily
ever after
jesus christ did i just [ __ ] quote
shrek
[Music]
it wouldn't be a gig video without some
anime girls and 2021 saw the tale of two
waifus on the opposite side of the
spectrum i can't pick between so i'm
gonna cheat and put them in the same
place on one side we've got the cute but
quiet komi-san she's hashtag relatable
because she's a super introvert
i knew that and she has trouble speaking
because she has social anxiety i do that
but she's so beautiful and good looking
that everyone respects her and wants to
be friends with her anyway
and on the other side is nagatoro
basically just a dojin character who
found herself her own anime with enough
smug energy to power the entire nation
of switzerland before airing these were
the two anime girls that dominated every
profile picture i'd see and i thought
2021 would be the war of the anime
profile pictures where komi sims and
nagatoro fans would compete over which
profile picture would get clowned on the
most on the internet then out of nowhere
nft bros appeared and went hold my
circus both of these shows follow its
own simple formula that just works
seeing comey's journey of conquering her
social anxiety just triggered this
innate desire in me to protect at all
cost but the biggest surprise was
nagatoro i thought this was only going
to appeal to the average discord user
who has the aspiration to one day be
stepped on i mean just look at this
devious smile look at the way she's
making this guy cry look at this face
and tell me she didn't just post memes
in general the [ __ ] but seeing the
relationship develop between the
unlikely couple was just the most
wholesome surprise for the year the
smile far exceeded the smug and i
couldn't help but get invested it's just
simple pure light-hearted fun on all
sides of the spectrum so what can i say
except it's wholesome
what can i say except it's awesome
alan got that
i remember the first time watching shows
like serial experiments lane evangelion
fooly cooley and not being able to
understand anything i'd watched at all
yet something about them stuck with me
like a parasite in my thoughts that i
didn't come to fully appreciate until
years after i had first watched them and
i have a feeling that sunnyboy is gonna
do exactly that for me sunnyboy is
easily the most overlooked anime of 2021
hell even i overlooked it until one day
i was just randomly recommended the oc
to the show on youtube and on a whim i
gave it a listen and instantly i just
fell in love i needed to know what this
show was about
sometimes you don't watch a show because
of something concrete that you can
verbalize but because of a feeling it
gives you and i don't know how i can say
that without sounding like some
pretentious art snob but i have no other
way to describe it its complex
multifaceted message is hidden behind a
web of story paths steeped in surrealism
that i can't even begin to untangle from
the concept of death to the inner depths
of the human psyche to the nature of
life itself it's not ideas that will
immediately leave an impact on you but
ones that slowly soak and seep in over
time i'm not gonna pretend i understood
everything about this anime but i can
already tell that part of it is gonna
stick with me for years to come i just
finished the show a month ago and i
already feel nostalgic about it it won't
be appreciated immediately but just give
it a few years and i swear to god this
is one of those anime that will have
aged like fine wine
2021 was the year mecca anime came back
with the vengeance we've got to see 2d
mechs again we're going to see sequels
to old beloved ips we've got to see
sequels to new beloved ips we got to see
the greatest thing to ever exist gundam
hathaway
alan have you been tampering with my
script again the right at the forefront
was 86 watching 86 made me feel like i
was a new anime fan again discovering
mecca in the mid-2000s anime boom it's
been so long since i've seen a good
old-fashioned military mecha show engage
old fans while introducing a plethora of
new ones to the genre right off the bat
we're introduced to a nation at war that
seems to be reminiscent to world war two
germany so you're like oh okay it's a
story where racism bad and indeed racism
is bad to racism no but as the show goes
on and then lays get peeled back you
start to realize there's so much more
play here the horrors of war the
corruption that comes with it and the
desperation of survival that can drive
any person to commit atrocities in the
name of victory it constantly keeps you
guessing keeps you thinking season one
sets up the stakes sets up the drama
only to have season two shatter
everything you knew about the world it
presented this feels like a long lost
generabuchi show from his prime and i
hope this is just the first of many
upcoming mecha shows that can introduce
a lot more of the current new generation
of anime fans to the genre
[Music]
you jojo in it if you think you can
graduate from this school
without kissing my [ __ ]
you are the drunk
[Music]
at this point i'm just convinced studio
wits have hacked enabled because i don't
think it's actually possible for them to
make a bad show vv was just a showcase
of what happens when you have a top tier
production in every aspect take a time
travel terminator plot line with a
badass female cyborg full-fledged action
hero written by the guy who wrote
re-zero with wit absolutely smurfing on
the animation and what you have is a
complete exhilarating ride from start to
finish this year was the year of anime
original shows and vv is the prime
example of what happens when it goes
right this felt like watching a
hollywood blockbuster production in
anime form and my god was it a joy to
see
[Music]
pretty much the only negative thing i
could say about it is that it does
everything great but doesn't do anything
exceedingly great animation writing
characters music this was a top
contender for pretty much every category
while having a show or two that did a
better job in one of those aspects it's
the master of everything but grand
master of none and the fact that it's
number seven is more of a testament to
how tough the competition was in the top
ten rather than how much of an
all-around banger this series
was souls prepare to cry edition but
sometimes no amount of emotional prep
can prepare you to your eternity follows
the journey of an immortal
shape-shifting object gaining sentience
from the people and experiences it
encounters there's a poetic beauty in
watching something that's the furthest
thing from what you can call mortal
discovering its own humanity from the
small pieces of everyone it meets after
watching a single episode a single arc
you know how the series is going to play
out you prepare for the worst with
everyone that meets but it breaks you
down anyway because it just carries this
emotional weight that pulls down on your
heart no matter how strong it is what
does it mean to live forever what is
there to be scared of when death isn't a
fear how do you go on living when
everything around you does not to your
eternity erects this wall around your
heart tears it down helps you build it
back up just so you can shatter it over
and over again but every time you let it
because like fushi a part of that
journey sticks with you with every new
wall that you build for a lot of us
there is nothing more frightening than
death but to me there's something
inherently beautiful about taking a
being that cannot die and teaching it
what it means to be alive
every minute
for years now a chinese animation has
been knocking out the door of the anime
community for one massive hit one super
sensation and in 2021 we went wait is
this what i think it is a succulent
chinese meal link click doesn't [ __ ]
around when it comes to introducing you
to its premise from the very first shot
we are showing the rules we are showing
the characters we understand the stakes
the curtains roll the stage is set and
your thrust head first into a super wild
ride the concept immediately grabs you
pulls you in and refuses to let go
you're put on the first episode five
minutes pass and then you finish episode
5. time travel is a concept that's been
explored to hell and back but it's
genuinely refreshing and addicting when
you find an angle that hasn't been done
before and link click capitalizes on
this to the fullest i know there's going
to be that one comment saying hey giggle
this isn't really anime and well i mean
you can watch the official japanese
anime stuff if that makes you happy
because i think this is just going to be
the start of high quality chinese
animation having more of a presence in
the anime community years ago
i was chinese
we get told the phrase never judge a
book by its cover time and time again
and then time and time again we go
what the [ __ ] is this stupid children's
cartoon doing my seasonal anime chart
skip on the surface ranking of kings
looks like your typical cheesy fairy
tale of a deaf prince fighting against
all odds to become the greatest king in
the world i mean just look at this
little munchkin what could possibly go
wrong then episode 2 comes out you see
this guy's entire clan gets massacred
while he escapes only to be rewarded by
the sight of his dead mother's corpse
being paraded around this guy gets to
see his dad's frozen body get crushed
into mush [ __ ] beheads a bird and is
forced to drink the blood from his head
this [ __ ] just goes ahead and chops
off his own hands clean off after a
fight the entire thing looks like a
children's story book but the things
that happen in it can be anything but
through all the cute wholesome moments
this is a mature tale with complex
multi-faceted characters that are always
more than meets the eye you got people
like the queen mother the typical evil
stepmom you see in every [ __ ] disney
movie who's scheming to give her own son
the throne at any cost except when it's
shown she just doesn't want to give the
insane pressure of becoming king to her
disabled stepson and actually loves and
cares for him as much as her real son
and you can find examples like this all
over the show as soon as you think you
know a character they'll do something
unexpected that adds an extra layer of
depth to them people with minimal lines
feel like they have a complexity to them
that most shows can't give in an entire
season even the slimiest person has
their morals even the most noble of
people can be slimy ranking of kings is
an absolute master class in storytelling
it feels like a storybook yet plays out
like a historical epic written by george
r.r martin this could very much be an
anime of the year 2022 in the making if
the second half follows through with
everything this first half has built up
this is an incredible show i almost miss
myself because of my preconceptions so i
swear to god this is the last time i'll
be judging a book by its cover
[Music]
what is the stupid furry bait doing on
my seasonal anime chart
oh [ __ ] odd taxi cemented the sentiment
this year that the best shows came from
the most unlikely of places on the
surface this looks like the furthest
thing from anime of the year contender
material but odd taxi doesn't need fancy
animation aesthetic character designs or
a big studio budget behind it because it
has the audacity to just try and carry
itself with sheer engrossing writing
which it does while most shows fail to
absorb you in a single plot line odd
taxi manages to engross you in ten with
grounded characters and dialogue so
punchy it'll make you sit down and go
damn
word got hands it's a show that treats
you with more of a level of respect than
i treat my best friends
taste in food there's no hand holding
here you are shown what you are needed
to be shown one scene one piece of
dialogue at a time this shot showed this
item okay this piece goes here that
character mentioned that thing okay so
that piece goes there piece by piece
this puzzle starts to unravel itself
what seems like a pool of unconnected
storylines slowly starts to form a
coherent hole but the full picture is
never clear until the very last moment
where the show stands up takes off his
bathrobe and [ __ ] slaps you faster than
you can say do you want my rod or this
rod the climactic ending didn't just
land on two feet it did a double
twisting somersault in the process
backflipped as an encore then bowed out
to a serenade of applause it's shows
like these that just reaffirm my faith
in anime it shows me that there are
still creators out there willing to make
original provocative works of art in an
industry saturated with mediocrity and
pandering and that there is still
someone out there who is willing to take
the risk to approve it no matter how
much i'll gravitate to the hundredth
isagile the next big shonen powerhouse
it's finding gems like these that keep
me coming back and i hope to god that
they never stop being made
[Music]
the ending of breaking bad the original
star wars trilogy the conclusion to the
infinity war saga i don't think in my
history of being an anime fan has it
felt like a show transcended from just
being a simple anime to a full-blown
cultural event but that's exactly what i
felt watching the final season of attack
on titan i went into the year thinking
the hype couldn't peak harder than it
did at the end of season 3 but attack on
titan season 4 dropped so hard my
grandma thought the germans had come
back it's ready to see a series with the
balls to attempt a story with the sheer
scale and ambition of the plot on
display here and it's even rarer to see
one that actually manages to follow
through with it to call this season a
new look would be an understatement
because until you saw some familiar
faces no one would even blame you for
thinking you put on the wrong [ __ ]
show and even then you still probably
wouldn't recognize them mikasa went new
haircut who this aaron's gone from hello
sir nice to meet you too maria isn't the
only thing getting smashed tonight an
armin is
finally taller than everyone else the
villains we hated are now our heroes and
the heroes we looked up to are now the
villains new characters new settings new
conflict an entirely new genre of show
and it somehow feels like this was the
only direction the story could have ever
gone just how seeing the evolution of
attack on titan from season 1 has not
just been a delight for recent shows
i've seen but one of the biggest
delights i've had as an anime fan period
regardless of how it ends this has done
what few series will ever be able to do
and whether it lands on two feet or
falls flat on its face this coming year
you bet your ass i'm gonna be chomping
down on that popcorn the entire way
[Music]
and i think it's an understatement to
say that in all my years of being an
isekai fan keeping faith while wading
through the dozens of the same copy
paste shows for the last decades that
this was the show i was waiting for
mushoka tensei isn't just amazing for
anita guy it isn't just amazing for a
fantasy it is just an amazing show it's
been such a long time since i watched
something that awoke that pure childish
sense of adventure that just made me
feel like i was going on a grand
adventure with my friends getting
completely lost in a totally new world
the world sucks you in and immerses you
the water magic feels almost alive you
can feel the scorched air of the desert
landscape it's another world that's been
stunningly crafted and carefully brought
to life i can't begin to talk about how
good of a job the newly formed studio
binds did you see this
yeah this is just a throwaway training
scene this bread has more care put into
it than the entirety of seven deadly
sins season three but it maintains this
quality through every second of its run
time the series has the best action
scenes the best dance scenes the best
subtle character moments the best
bread scenes but it goes beyond just
animation the music the cinematography
the voice acting they invented not just
one but two made-up languages for
different races of this fictional world
which can and has been translated which
is absolutely insane there's an episode
which is like 80 spoken in made up
languages just to further immerse you in
this world studio binds poured their
[ __ ] hearts into every single little
detail and it shows each frame has more
love and care put into it than most
anime get in an entire season but behind
this masterful craft there's also just a
real heart behind the story being told
here being a part of rudius's long
journey of learning from his mistakes of
his previous life is just an absolute
joy to be a part of there are many
things about our protagonist that will
understandably put people off the show
and look i get it and i don't stand
behind it either because let's not
forget he's this guy but the series
never lets you forget how flawed of a
guy he is and every tiny lesson he
learns every small thing he does to
change his actions for the better just
makes you want to stand up and go yes
that's it that's what i'm talking about
this isn't a show where i found myself
projecting on the main character but
instead cheering him on to become a
better person this is no longer the
self-insert isakai it's a
self-reflection itakai and i think this
is true for every single person in the
show his dad kind of an [ __ ] but
learns from it because parents are still
human after all heiress well she's your
typical short fused violent tinder [ __ ]
you've seen in every other anime so what
happens
she gets the [ __ ] beaten out of her now
she knows there are times to be patient
characters learn and grow from their
mistakes everyone is on their own
personal journey you see people flawed
people fighting to be the best person
they can be after all this time i
finally understood what isakai was meant
to be about a story that didn't just
ignore a person's previous life but used
it as a stepping stone to find the path
to a better one a series that didn't
just show you another world but made you
feel like you're a part of it this is
what i want jiseki for this is what
animation was made for and this is why a
god damn [ __ ] love anime isekai trash
nah
i only watch isekai treasure
[Music]
but anyway i've talked for far too long
already even having to cut out so many
other shows i enjoyed but didn't have
enough to say about we got it all this
year the good the bad the ugly the weird
the epic the funny and the downright
beautiful it's been an up and down year
for me overall but it's been you guys
that have helped me get through it and
whether 2021 was a great year for you or
not you can't deny
it was a pretty great year for anime
what is that
[Music]
hello guys hope you're enjoying the new
year so far thank you very much this
month too alpha sigma basil
dysfunctional degenerate elephant aivito
jeff levardos manopla payne patchett
pony stark walter and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible you know what guys before you
comment i do have one little addition i
wanted to add to the list
because this was way longer than a lot
of my usual videos so i had to cut some
stuff out and so i wanted to give a
shout out to arcane because i know it's
technically not anime but as much as i
loved mushoka tensei if arcane was an
anime it would probably be my anime of
the year if not it's definitely my
animation of this year and i'm sad i had
to cut it out but i didn't want to keep
you guys waiting any longer for this
video also if you enjoyed my rundown of
the top anime of this year then you'd
probably be interested in what i vote
for for the anime awards this year and
literally as i'm recording this right
now crunchyroll just released their
nominations so i'm gonna be doing a live
stream just going through all the
nominations and picking who i'm going to
vote for that's going to be on monday
the 24th of january so if everything
goes to plan with the schedule of this
upload that should be tomorrow or the
day after touchwood because i'm filming
this a few days before anyway that's it
for me for today hope you enjoyed the
video hope you've had a great 2021 and
let's hope 2022 treats us well i've been
giggup and i'll see you all next time